-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging out with
Jamie Dornan.
And we are about to play
another edition of
"Like, Follow, Block."
-♪ Like, follow, block ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ Yeah! ♪
-Alright. Now, to start off,
I'm I'm going to
give you three choices, and
you're gonna have to tell me,
out of the three, which would
you like a post from,
which one you'd follow,
and which one you would block.
Sound good?
-I've got this.
-Alright, let's see
the first three options.
-That's alarmingly easy for me.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah, it is.
So, straightaway --
like, follow, block --
blocking Bailey's.
I just do not understand
Bailey's at all.
I don't understand why it's --
Bailey's should be blocked
for life, for good, forever.
-It's like Irish eggnog.
-No, it's sickening.
I, like -- Don't get me
started on Bailey's.
Jameson I'm going to like,
'cause I do. I like it.
And, yeah, I'm gonna follow --
I would follow Guinness
anywhere it leads me. Yeah.
-"I would follow Guinness
anywhere it leads me"
should actually be
the slogan for Guinness.
That is fantastic.
Next round, we have...
-Okay.
-Are you a "Friends" fan?
-Yeah. Yeah, I mean, listen,
I feel like everyone
kind of is a "Friends" fan,
and I feel like I must have
seen every "Friends."
And we do a thing sometimes,
my wife and I.
If we want to watch, like,
a really serious series
but we're eating, we'll be like,
"Why don't we just
stick 'Friends' on
while we wait."
That's, like, our thing.
-Yeah, yeah.
-So I always eat during
"Friends."
-That's so funny.
-You know, I'm quite classic in
my "Friends" appreciation.
So I'm going to follow
Ross and Rachel.
-Yeah.
-Chandler and Monica
will get a like.
-Wow.
-And it's actually nothing
against Joey and Phoebe,
but, yeah, I'm blocking them.
-Yeah, it's a tough choice.
I understand.
We have to do
another round here.
We got...
-Wow.
-Mm-hmm.
-What is the lesser of
these three evils?
[ Both laugh ]
I guess I'll follow Instagram,
because I'm on there.
I'll like Twitter
because I used to be on there.
And I'll block Facebook
'cause I have no
experience in Facebook.
-I love the honesty.
I appreciate it. I get it.
Last round.
I'm going to pronounce these
the way I think
they should be pronounced.
We have Batmin, Spider-min,
and Iron Min.
Am I pronouncing it wrong?
-It works for me.
It works for me.
-Batman, Spider-man, Iron Man.
-Oh, wow. Okay.
-Like, follow, block.
-I'm gonna -- I wouldn't want
to block Batman.
I'm most scared of him of
the three of the them.
So he's gonna --
You know, I'll follow him.
Spider-man I am going to like.
And I'm gonna block Iron Man
because I just don't like what
he's doing in that image there.
I don't like that.
He's super-aggressive
in that image,
and I'm like, "No, thanks."
[ Both laugh ]
-He is a bit intimidating.
Like, You don't want to have
that dude at a party right now.
But, yet, in real life,
he's fun,
but at that moment --
Yeah, from the picture alone,
I totally agree
with these choices.
Jamie Dornan, everybody.
"Wild Mountain Thyme"
is out December 11th.
Thank you so much
for being here, pal.
It's always good to see you.